- Happy Thanksgiving is
tomorrow. So happy Thanksgiving.
- Thanks. You too.
- Yeah, but last time you were here,
we didn't get to talk about your daughter.
So how are you handling,
having a teenager?
I just want to know cause
mine's seven right now.
- Yeah.
- [Clarkson] I feel like she's a teenager.
- [Audience] Awwww!
- [Clarkson] She is so stinking adorable.
And how you look is so awesome.
(audience laughing)
This is my favorite picture.
- Thank you.
- It should be your Christmas card.
- That's my lock screen actually.
- Oh my God. I love that.
Mine are my kids too.
- I mean, it's great. I trust her opinion
more than I trust my own now.
Like she has her finger
on the pulse of like,
what's hot Or like, if I'm doing a song
and it's the right one,
like she'll confirm it--
- Oh, I love that.
- She also has, like.
- Does she also tell you
when it's crap? (laughs)
- Oh yeah. For sure.
- Because my daughter
does and she's seven.
- But she has like, she always
just gets into funny phases,
which is like, maybe she gets that from me
except I run all mine into the ground.
Like I like--
(laughing)
- You're like, wear out?
- Yeah, I wear it out. Like
I have this thing right now
where I'm like respectfully,
and I like, say anything
and not just follow it with, respectfully.
- I say, honestly, what does
that mean? Am I going to lie?
Like I say, honestly a lot.
- But she has one that,
what does she say right now?
Oh, she goes, you thought you ate that?
And like, she has a bunch of uncles
because all of my band
mate, all of my friends
or whatever, all like her uncles.
So if they ever like, picking
on her or anything like that,
she's like, you thought you ate that?
- Like, what does it mean?
- I think it means like, oh,
you thought that was funny
- Ow, you though that was great.
- Or you thought you killed that.
- I'm going to steal
that one and I'm going
to look so cool saying it
and not like a mom at all.
Is she into sports? Does she play sports?
- Yeah. I just took her
to volleyball try outs.
She came up to me with
like recruitment papers
and stuff like that and I
was like, whoa, what is this?
Like the NBA draft and then like,
but my favorite part was I looked at
the contract and I was like, Casie, dude,
they're going to pay you 800 or $1,800
and then I looked closer
and I was like, oh,
I have to pay 1800 dollars, Right.
- I was like, what kind of school is this.
- That's what I said,
because she was like,
I need you to take me to trials
And this was like, in-between,
on an off day of the tour.
So I went back to Cleveland to take her
to the trials and yeah, they came up,
they were like super, it was like 250 kids
and they were like, you know, here,
like we want her on the national team.
Like it's, you know, and
it was like super serious.
and I looked and I saw like the $1,800,
I was like, dude, you're like
a professional sports player.
And then yeah,
(kelly laughing)
- it was, it was me that had to
- And then you like,
having to pay it, yeah.
I love volleyball. It's such a fun thing.
Did you play sports?
- I played. I mean, no
one will believe me,
but I played football for a little bit.
- Why would I not believe?
Aren't you from Texas?
Don't all men in Texas, when
you're young, play football?
- Well, I lived there for two weeks,
so technically I can't really...
(audience laughing)
- Even two weeks, when you're there
and they see a guy they're like
put a football in your hand.
- Right.
- Its like very , Friday night lights.
- But then I went to
Egypt and that's where
I spent my first six years of my life.
I don't think I played
football much over there
except for like the kick kind.
- That's the coolest thing ever though ,
I've been to Egypt. It's a cool place.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, okay. Well wait,
are you the dad at the game,
Like when you go to like
the sporting events,
are you a yeller? Are you
that embarrassing dad?
- So I always rolled deep to the games.
- You bring a posse?
- Yeah. so I'm more just kind of like
laugh at what they're saying.
But last game we went
to, my dude was like,
so she's she served it or she served it
and it went to this
person who like, you know,
was the weakest link in
this section or whatever.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And my guy goes, I'm not
telling you what to do,
but if you see something
you like keep going for it,
(kelly laughing)
basically like keep
hitting it right there.
- Just keep killing that kids confidence?
- Yeah, she's never gonna return it.
- Ow my god!
- And I'm always like, just bummed,
like what if their parents like a fan,
and they just think that we're like,
- Hassling their kid?
- Yeah, just trolling their kids.
- "Hey that kid sucks,
serve it to that one."
The mom on the end is like,
are you for real right now?